i have this matrix a here that i want to
put into reduced row echelon form and
we've done this multiple times you just
perform a bunch of row operations but
what i want to show you in this video is
that those row operations are equivalent
to linear transformations on the column
vectors of a
so let me show you by example so if we
just want to put a into reduced row
echelon form the first step that we
might want to do if we want to zero out
these entries right here
is
let me do it right here is we'll keep
our first entry the same so for each of
these column vectors we're going to keep
the first entry the same so they're
going to be 1
minus 1 minus 1. and actually let me
simultaneously construct my
transformation so i'm saying that what
my row operation i'm going to perform is
equivalent to
a linear transformation on the column
vector so it's going to be a
transformation
that's going to take some column vector
a1 a2 and a3
it's going to take each of these and
then do something to them and do
something to them in a linear way
they'll be linear transformations
so we're keeping the first entry of our
column vector the same so this is just
going to be a1
it's just going to be a1 this is a line
right here that's going to be a1 now
what could we do if we want to get to
reduce row echelon form we'd want to put
make this equal to zero so when we want
to replace our second row with the
second row plus the first row because
then these wood guys would turn out to
be zero so let's let me write that in my
transformation i'm going to replace the
second row with the second row
plus the first row with the second row
plus the first row and let me write it
out here minus one plus one is zero two
plus minus one is one three plus minus
one is two
now we also want to get a zero here so
let me replace my third row with my
third row
minus my first row so i'm going to
replace my third row with my third row
minus my first row
so 1 minus 1 is
1 minus minus 1
is 2
4 minus minus 1
is 5
just like that so you see this was just
a linear transformation and any linear
transformation you could actually
represent as a matrix vector product so
for example this transformation i could
represent it and let me to figure out
its transformation matrix so if we say
that t
of x
is equal to i don't know let's call it
some let's call it sum at some matrix s
times x we already used the matrix a so
i have to pick another letter
so how do we find s well we just apply
the transformation to all of the column
vectors or the standard basis vectors of
the identity matrix so let's do that so
the identity matrix i'll draw it really
small like this
the identity matrix looks like this one
zero zero
zero one zero zero zero one that's what
the identity matrix looks like to find
the transformation matrix we just apply
this guy to each of the column vectors
of this
so what do we get
do a little bit bigger
so the first
we apply it to each of these column
vectors but we see the first row always
stays the same so the first row is
always going to be the same thing so 1
zero zero i'm essentially applying it
simultaneously to each of these column
vectors saying look when you take each
of when you transform each of these
column vectors their first entry stays
the same the second entry the second
entry becomes the second entry plus the
first entry so zero plus one is one one
plus zero
is one zero plus zero is zero
and then the third entry the third entry
gets replaced with the third entry minus
the first entry so zero minus one is
minus one zero minus zero
is zero and then one minus zero is one
now notice when i applied this
transformation to the column vectors of
our identity matrix i essentially just
performed those same row operations that
i did up there i performed those exact
same row operations on this identity
matrix but we know that this is actually
the transformation matrix that if we
multiply it by each of these column
vectors we will or by each of these
column vectors we're going to get these
column vectors so you could view it this
way let me call this this is right here
this is equal to s
this is our transformation matrix
so if we we could say that
we could say that s
if we create a new matrix
whose columns are s times
this column vector s times 1 minus 1 1
and then the next column is s times
s times
i wanted to do in that other color
this guy
minus 1 2 1
and then the third column is going to be
the third column is going to be s
times
s times this third column vector
minus 1 3
4.
this product we now know we're applying
this transformation this is s times each
of these column vectors that is the
matrix representation of this
transformation we will this guy right
here
this guy will be transformed to this
right here that'll become let me do it
down
let me do it oh down here
this guy i wanted to show that stuff
that i had above here as well
well i'll just draw an arrow that's
probably the simplest thing this matrix
right here will become that matrix right
there so another way you could write it
this is equivalent to what what is this
equivalent to when you take a matrix and
you multiply it times each of the column
vectors when you transform each of the
column vectors by this matrix
this is the definition of a matrix
matrix product this is equal to our
matrix s i'll do it in pink this is
equal to our matrix s which is 1
0 0
1 1 zero minus one zero one
times our matrix a
times
times one minus one
one
minus one
two one
minus 3 sorry minus 1 3 4.
so let me make this very clear this is
our matrix this is our transformation
matrix s
this is our matrix a
and when you perform this product when
you perform this product you're going to
get this guy right over here
you're going to get this guy right over
here just copy and paste it
edit let me copy
let me paste it
you're going to get that guy
just like that now the whole reason why
i'm doing that is just to remind you
that when we perform each of these row
operations we're just multiplying we're
performing a linear transformation on
each of these columns and it is
completely equivalent to just
multiplying this guy by some matrix s in
this case we took the trouble of
figuring out what that matrix s is but
any of these row operations that we've
been doing you can always represent them
by a matrix multiplication you can
always represent them by matrix
multiplication so this leads to a very
interesting idea
this leads to a very interesting idea
when you when you put something in
reduced row echelon form let me do it up
here
so let me
let me
actually let's just finish what we've we
started with this guy let's put this guy
in reduced row echelon form
so this we already said this is equal to
let me call this first s let's call that
s1 so this guy right here
is equal to that first s1 times a
we we already showed that that's true
now let's perform another transformation
or let's just do another set of row
operations to get us to reduce row
echelon form so let's keep our middle
row the same
0 1 2 and let's replace the first row
with the first row plus the second row
because i want to make this a 0. so 1
plus 0 is 1. let me do another color 1
plus 0 is 1
minus 1 plus one is zero
minus one plus two is one
now i wanna replace the third i wanna
replace the third row but let's say
let's say the third row
minus two times the first row third row
minus two times the first row so that's
zero minus two times zero is zero
two minus two times one is zero
five minus two times two
is one five minus four is
and we're almost there we just have to
zero out these guys right there see if
we can get this into reduced row echelon
form so what is this i just performed
another linear transformation actually
let me write this let's see if this was
our first linear transformation what i
just did is i performed another linear
transformation t2 i'll write in a
different notation where you give me
some vector some column vector x1 x2 x3
what did i just do
what was the transformation that i just
performed my new vector i made the top
row equal to the top row plus the second
row so this x1 plus x2 i kept the second
row the same and then the third row i
replaced it with the third row
minus 2 times the second row that was a
linear transformation we just did and we
could represent this linear
transformation as being we could say t2
applied to some vector x is equal to
some transformation vector s2 times our
vector x
now we could say that this
this is equal to
we could say
because if we applied
this transformation matrix to each of
these columns it's equivalent to
multiplying this guy by this
transformation matrix so you could say
that this guy right here we haven't
figured out what this is but i think you
get the idea
this matrix right here is going to be
equal to this guy it's going to be equal
to s2
times this guy and what is this guy
right here well this guy is equal to s1
times a so it's going to be s2 times
s1
times a
fair enough so this is just s2 times s1
times a and you could have gotten
straight here if you created a new if
you just multiplied s2 times s1 this
could be some other matrix and you just
multiplied it by a you'd go straight
from there to there fair enough now we
still haven't gotten this guy in reduced
row echelon form so let's try to get
there and i've run out of space below
him so i'm going to have to go up
so let's go upwards
let's go upwards like this
and what i want to do is i'm going to
keep the third row the same
keep the third row the same zero zero
one and let me replace
let me replace the second row
with the second row minus two times the
third row so we'll get a zero we get a
one minus two times zero and we get a
two
minus two times one so that's a zero
and let's replace the first row with the
first row minus the third row so one
minus zero is one
zero minus zero is zero and 1 minus 1
is 0
just like that and since we did them for
the analysis actually write what our
transformation was let's call it t3 i'll
do it in purple
t3
t3 is the transformation on some vector
x let me write it like this
on some vector x1 x2 x3
it was equal to what did we do we
replaced the first row with the first
row minus the third row x one minus x
three
we replaced the second row with the
second row minus two times the third row
so it's x two minus two times x three
and then the third row just stayed the
same so obviously this could also be
represented this could also be
represented t3 of x
could be equal to some other
transformation matrix s3 times x
so this transformation when you multiply
it to each of these columns is
equivalent to
is equivalent to multiplying this guy
times this transformation matrix which
we haven't found yet well we can write
it so this is going to be equal to s3
s3 times this matrix right here which is
s2
s1
a and what do we have here we got the
identity matrix we put it in reduced row
echelon form we got the identity matrix
and we already know from previous videos
if you the reduced row echelon form of
something is the identity matrix then we
are dealing with an invertible
transformation or an invertible matrix
because this obviously could be the
transformation for some transformation
let's just call this transformation
i don't know let's just call it t did i
already use t well let's just call it t
naught
for our transformation
applied to some vector x it might be
equal to a x so we know that this is we
know that this is invertible
because we put it in reduced row echelon
form we put its transformation matrix
and reduced row echelon form and we got
the identity matrix so that tells us
that's an invertible but something even
more interesting happened we got here by
performing some row operations and we
said those row operations were
equivalent were completely equivalent to
multiplying this guy right here by
getting multiplying our original
transformation matrices matrix by a
series of transformation matrices that
represent our row operations when we
multiplied all this this was equal to
the identity matrix
now in the last video we said that the
inverse matrix so if this is t naught t
naught inverse
t naught inverse could be represented
it's also linear transformation it can
be represented by some
inverse matrix that we just called a
inverse times x and we saw that a
inverse
a inverse times or the inverse
transformation matrix times our
transformation matrix is equal to the
identity matrix
we saw this
last time
we proved this to you now something very
interesting here we have a series of
matrix products times this guy times
this guy that also got me the identity
matrix
so this guy right here
the series of matrix products this must
be
this must be the same thing as my
inverse matrix as my inverse
transformation matrix and so we could
actually calculate if we wanted to we
could actually just like we did we've
actually figured out what s1 was we did
it down here we could do a similar
operation to figure out what s2 was s3
was and then multiply them all out and
we would have actually constructed a
inverse
but something
i guess something more interesting we
could do instead of doing that what if
we started off what if we applied the
same if we applied these same
matrix products or to the
to the identity matrix so the whole time
we did here we did our first row
operation so we have here we have the
matrix a
and let's say we have an identity matrix
on the right let's call that i
right there now our first linear
transformation we did we saw that right
here that was equivalent to
multiplying s1
times a
right the first set of row operations
was this it got us here now if we
perform that same set of row operations
on the identity matrix what are we going
to get we're going to get the matrix s1
s1 times the identity matrix is just s1
all of the columns of
anything times the identity times the
standard basis columns will just be
equal to themselves and you'll just be
left with that s1 or you could call this
as s1 times i but that's just s1 fair
enough now you performed your next row
operation and you ended up with
s2 times s1 times a
now if you perform that same row
operation on this guy right there what
would you have you would have s2 times
s1 times the identity matrix
now our last row operation we
represented with the matrix product s3
or multiplying it by the transformation
matrix s3 so if you did that if you have
s3 s2 s1a but if you perform the same
exact row operations on this guy right
here you have s3 s2
s1 times the identity matrix now when
you did this when you perform these row
operations here this got you to the
identity matrix but what are these going
to get you to
this is when you just perform the same
exact row operations you perform on a to
get to the identity matrix if you
perform those same exact row operations
on the identity matrix what do you get
well you get this guy right here
right anything times the identity matrix
is going to be equal to itself so what
got what is that right there that is a
inverse
that is a inverse so we have a
generalized way of figuring out the
inverse for the inverse for
transformation matrix what i can do is
let's say i have some transformation
matrix a
i can set up an augmented matrix where i
put the identity matrix right there
just like that
and i perform a bunch of row operations
i perform a bunch of row operations
and you could represent them as matrix
products but you perform a bunch of row
operations on all of them you perform
the same operations you perform on a as
you would do on the identity matrix and
by the time you have a in as an identity
matrix you have a in reduced row echelon
form
at time a is like that your identity
matrix is going to the
having performed the same exact
operations on it it is going to be
transformed into a's inverse and this is
a very useful tool for solving actual
inverses now i've explained kind of the
theoretical reason why this works in the
next video we'll actually solve this
maybe we'll do it for this the example
that i started off with in this video